Kevin halford and Steve [inaudible].
So welcome guys.
Alright,
yeah,
we're super pumped.
The guys have,
you guys are at Google where going saw the film last night is so phenomenal and
it has such a cool story of how you guys got it made,
which was you guys started in Indeigogo,
uh,
big crowds starter campaign and um,
it was so crowdfunding campaign and it was so cool to see that you guys
announced it and then have it launch it within a day or two and basically racked
up basically your goal,
which was like $2 million,
right?
Yeah.
Ended up with 4.75.
Yup.
That's very good.
Yeah.
But humbling,
very humbling.
You know,
we were pretty anxious about it going in,
you know,
uh,
we knew that the studio in particular wasn't sure that the fans were still out
there and we had no idea how this was going to go down.
So we did a lot of preparation.
We made content for the 30 days of the entire campaign.
And,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
somebody bought the $35,000 squad car within the first hour or two a,
we got interested a lot of save the date for our package to be a,
the groomsmen at the,
at the wedding.
I was at $25,000 back.
But yeah,
we got $2 million in two ways from doing that.
The save the date.
We tried,
we tried,
somebody actually did an Indiegogo campaign to fund,
uh,
bringing us to their wedding,
but I don't think they raised the money for that one.
But it could have gone the other way.
I mean it,
you know,
if,
if people didn't care,
fund it,
the studio would have said,
well,
we're,
you're not making it,
you know,
we're not going to release a movie.
Nobody wants to see.
Yeah.
Well,
did you have any inkling in terms of like,
is this going to do well?
Like did you,
did you,
when you,
before you did have you,
obviously you're nervous,
but what,
what made it now it's like this is,
you know,
moving,
making eh,
in order to think you can make a film starring you and your friends and get it
into
theaters,
you have to be like a real relaxed kind of dumb high stakes gambler.
Right?
I mean you,
you,
you make outrageous requests of people like to fund this movie with us in it.
And uh,
and it,
it,
it sometimes it works,
right?
I mean,
and so taking that risk was for us,
we were like sure.
But also I think the first one was a very grassroots kind of feeling movie.
You know,
it didn't have like a huge box office thing,
but people saw it on DVD and they saw it in their living rooms and it had this
feeling,
this grassroots feeling,
which I think the crowd funding thing lend itself for
to where people want it to be directly involved in their own way.
Yeah.
Cause it did well in the box office,
but it really,
how I discovered it was actually on DVD.
Yeah.
And so,
which is a market that doesn't exist.
That's right.
Yeah.
Thanks to California
disrupting ticking off technology.
Thanks.
I guess in this era though,
when you have,
um,
you have Netflix and Hulu and Amazon,
but I guess the studio owned the rights,
so they weren't allowing it to basically,
okay.
Yeah.
They controlled the rights to the SQL and they basically,
they said to me,
we're not going to fund it,
but we're never going to let you make it somewhere else because we don't want it
to be a hit somewhere else and have us look bad.
So they said,
so you fund it,
and then if it's a hit,
then we'll fund the third one.
Oh Wow.
Really?
That's the way it is.
So then they said they gave us parameters and they said we had to raise,
you know,
a certain amount to shoot the movie.
And then also we had to raise the entire P and a,
the prints and advertising budget.
And they set that at $10 million.
And so ultimately the,
the raise we had to do was over $20 million and a,
and so the crowdfunding campaign really kicked that off.
Um,
you know,
got us four and a half million dollars.
It got us the confidence of the studio and it enabled us to shoot for seven days
and like 20 pages of the,
of the movie.
Um,
and then we were able to get finance series on the back of that.
But in the end the studio came in and is paying for all the advertising.
Once they saw the movie,
we had to create the film first so it make it successful.
Yeah.
Right.
And was there any a point I guess,
I mean cause it's been 17 years now,
I guess,
since the original.
So was there any point during this 17 years where you want to do with SQL right
away?
Or was there just not a competence thing?
Cause it did do,
we didn't want to be,
um,
you know,
we didn't want to sort of follow and be the police academy guys.
It really more than anything.
It's like we want it to make other movies so that we wouldn't be only known for
that thing.
So we made,
you know,
club dread and beer fest and Simon Salmon.
Now we figured it was time to come back and grow the mustache.
Some didn't change.
We have a history and a history of a sketch comedy group for five years before
he made movies.
We were doing live sketch comedy shows in New York City.
So we always enjoyed playing,
trying different characters and different plots and stuff like that.
A little bit about the origins of Roman lizards.
So you guys all,
all in college,
right?
We're all part of Colgate university and was always you five or was it 14 first
was 14 people.
And so was there ever,
is there a last member of broken lizard and then several,
lots of them?
Yeah,
many.
Yeah.
But a lot of that,
I mean,
you know,
like in New York,
the only place that would allow us to perform when we were first in New York
City was a gay cabaret club called the duplex.
And,
um,
and the backstage that was just a teeny little stairwell,
it's probably like six stairs and an emergency exit.
And you know,
I think that group started off with nine people and,
uh,
the core group here,
like we just bugged the shit out of those people so badly that they quit one by
one,
like one guy.
And it was a tricky one guy in his letter of resignation said that like our mom
jokes gave him headaches and he couldn't stand to be with us anymore.
So here we are,
there's the fun.
Um,
so,
but you guys,
so the kicks are the Indiegogo started two of 2015.
Right?
It was one of 2015.
Then you shot it in twice at 16 or 17.
Trying to understand what we've,
what we've found out is we,
we'd raised the money and then I got to be kind of later in 2015 and then
someone informed us that if we didn't spend the money by the end of the year,
we had to pay taxes on the income.
So whatever,
you know,
half of it,
we'll have to go,
hey,
we have to go away to taxes if we didn't spend it.
So,
uh,
we immediately went into production and we,
we shot for about six or eight days or something like that to,
to,
to kind of start to start the ball rolling.
And then that,
like Steve said,
that's what helped us then raise the more money that we needed,
that one concept and then we shot the rest of the rate of 2016 because these
are,
these are the questions that come up,
you know,
an independent filmmaking too,
because the questions that we debated was,
all right,
well,
we've got this four and a half million dollars,
should we just shoot,
try to shoot the whole movie with us and do it really,
really,
really bare bones and then,
or should we just shoot a portion of it and make it as kick ass as we possibly
can.
So we shot the whole opening sequence that you saw last night,
um,
and then a bunch of the pullovers and the mountain uniforms and uh,
and it turned out great.
That was the whole thing also is that we finished it in 2016.
Uh,
and we shot,
we finished that,
then we did a little reshoot 70 and then the movie was in the can edited mixed
and done in the summer of 2017 and we went to the Fox studio and they said they
were trying to figure out a release date and we were hoping like late summer or
whatever it was.
And they're like,
you know,
for 20 falls on a Friday in 2018
so what do you mean?
It was like,
we're thinking about waiting until four 20 because we think it's the perfect
release date for you guys.
And we're like,
well that's eight months from now,
a year off our lives.
Uh,
and so that's,
you know,
ultimately the decision they made.
It was a marketing decision and then we were upset at the time.
But at this point now,
it just seems like a smart,
they've created a holiday for us release.
Our movie in Jag has used the director of both films.
Um,
now that you're at eight months is such like sit on it.
Was there a temptation to go back in and tweak it at all?
You know,
I watched it last night and I'm like,
there are about six changes.
I still want to make time.
It's done.
It's thousands of bricks.
I just closed my eyes during those,
those mums for you guys.
I mean you guys have,
obviously I'll write on the film,
right.
And wrote the,
wrote all these films were broken lizard.
And so what does that writer's room like when you guys are working together?
It's fun.
Uh,
it's,
I mean it's really fun.
We've known each other since college,
so it comes pretty easily.
Yeah.
Like riffing on trust.
I think we have a shorthand for how we work with each other.
I mean there's,
you know,
when we first started you'd get these ridiculous fights that would last,
hours over the stupidest joke or whatever it is.
I think we've learned how to be a little bit more efficient since the,
that time and uh,
and we can
insult each other and still come back the next day and be friends and we can
look,
families agree and whatever.
But the,
I think the bottom line of our writing room is if you can make the other guys
laugh,
it's going to get in the movie so that your sounding board is,
do you,
does your decision decisions?
Trump all this is the director know,
hey,
what
do you fight them on of stuff though there a,
there's a a bit from Steve Stand up that these guys wanted to put in the movie
because the,
you know,
they'd seen it on the,
on the standup station.
It really worked really well and they said,
we should do this,
this bed.
It's like this in the car.
Where are we at?
We're,
we're po,
we're posing as French speaking mounties right.
And so there was a,
there's a very dirty joke that,
that he has,
I won't ruin it,
but it's a very dirty joke that if you say it in French,
it sounds like something really dirty.
And he's,
they were like,
let's put this in the movie.
And I'm like,
Eh,
it's more of a standup joke.
And we fought for probably eight,
seven or eight drafts and they kept saying,
let's put it in the movie.
I'm like,
ah,
I don't really like it,
you know,
and then I have to start insulting the joke.
And then finally we put it into the thing and I'm like,
fine,
we'll shoot it.
I'll just cut it later.
Uh,
and then because of some,
I was in this one scene and then we had to juggle it based on the plot.
I ended up now in the scene and now I'm telling these jokes and I'm like,
I don't want to Kelly's Damn Joe.
Right.
And then we shoot it and we put it in a movie.
And of course it's the most popular scene in the movie.
And I'm like,
thank God I was in that,
in that scene
that happened sometimes fighting for a joke.
Sometimes like survivor,
you got to form alliances,
there's five of us and you try to get a majority,
right?
So if you really like a joke,
you sometimes try to form alliances.
You get a majority,
you got to sell it.
You've got to sometimes get on its feet and act it out.
And then if they see it like okay I get you're doing with that and they then
kind of get on board.
Oh yeah,
no it's,
it can be rough sometimes if you believe in something,
you just have to take a stand here and keep coming back draft after draft and
making your pitch and you'll take some ridicule.
It's guys will insult like everything you stand for.
But eventually one day like one guy will turn and be like,
you know,
now I like this fucking joke.
And then you can see it start to happen and then you have three or five of them
and you're like,
it's ducks have bats back and forth cause you do those in the movies.
Is that coming from real life where you pass back and forth where if this joke
works,
if this joke kills,
then you got Kevin and I are in the edit room,
uh,
and we will fight over whether a joke is funny or not.
And then when we get in the finally you look in the screening room last night,
I'm like,
fuck you dude.
Sometimes there's that silence.
You know
what?
He always does his like,
there'll be like,
it'll be a big laugh and joke.
I thought it was great and he'll go,
it was more of a grown
and then it will never give it.
Those are the best moments because it's like,
uh,
we'll have the test screening in front of a live audience for the first time.
It's not friends and family and the line is coming up.
It's coming and that happens and let's say there's a laugh,
you'll just see like two guys who had the disagreement.
We'll just
lean forward.
You record it for the labs,
but then you go back and you hear and you listened to see if they will laugh at
the joke when it's on the screen.
Can you talk about a little bit about the filmmaking process that you guys,
how it was back in the early 2006 now we have social media and now we have
digital cameras and everything is completely different than probably what you
guys experienced back in the,
yeah,
I mean the social media element is like when you make something,
uh,
artistic,
you know,
you're going to be attacked in some form,
right?
So it's like,
it's just sort of the way,
I mean,
everybody has a voice now,
anonymous voice,
which is too bad,
but the weight of whatever,
no,
it's fine.
Um,
but you know,
you just stepped to,
you know,
you have to really,
I mean,
it used to be that you opened the New York Times and they would insult your
movie and then,
and you know,
you're like,
Hey,
I'm here with my friends and relatives are reading this thing,
but now it's literally all over Twitter and everywhere.
Right.
So it's just the way it goes.
I mean,
there's a lot of,
you know,
you just have to try to keep the positive way of going.
Um,
like skin.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
Um,
and then in terms of your shoes out,
because you have continued to direct and shoot,
um,
a lot of series as well.
And so,
um,
how have you evolved,
I guess,
essentially as a filmmaker?
Like what did you,
I guess I've learned from your,
you know,
decades of working on film into that you put into this one?
You know,
I shout over a hundred episodes of television,
so,
uh,
I've shot,
you know,
25 sex scenes and 25 fights and bunch of dinner scenes.
And I tried different lenses and different scenes and handheld and dollies and I
kind of figured out what I like the most.
And then when we make a film,
I just do that favorite version.
And so it's,
it's made things,
you know,
like all the decision making in a,
how should I shoot this all that time that I would've spent thinking about it.
Now I already have an opinion about it.
Gotcha.
And as you guys are writing your characters and writing this together in the
room,
um,
you obviously have probably strong opinions for your characters and maybe other
characters.
Who is the most challenging?
The right for and who is the most fun to write for it?
Well,
I think we had a policy for a long time and obviously the SQL kind of blew it
out of the water but we always did was we would not cast the script until we had
written multiple,
multiple drafts.
Cause that's what happened.
It's like a guy when they go off to my character,
got to think of my jokes.
But if you keep it,
you know,
without being cast you can write for everybody.
And so we had kind of a long process where we did that.
This one was a little different now because you already knew what character you
were and then anything that was just fucking insane.
They just gave to my character.
We all right for him.
Those are the fun things.
It's like we have with server troopers.
We did a table read with each guy playing different roles,
basically auditioning to see,
you know,
for different parts.
I was supposed to read Farba after Kevin and so he read Pharma and then we were
done with that and we're like,
all right,
let's go again.
Steve,
do you want to,
you ready to play fire?
But I was like,
Nah,
I think we're done here.
We had tried to beforehand.
Yeah,
I tried Farba he tried Pharma and then he got Farber like you got it.
Got It.
Yeah.
We're just not,
we're not as big a difference as the asshole course.
And when you're,
um,
when you're writing a sequel,
a lot of times what happens is,
which does not happen in this film,
which is really,
really rare in terms of lot of sequels.
They end up tending to be basically a lot of the same jokes and a lot of same
stuff that you guys handled it really well where yes,
you do reference me out and funny things like that and like gafcon and stuff,
but you aren't,
you aren't retreading the same stuff.
It's like new jokes,
but kind of referencing the old,
but it's really,
really great.
We exist in the same world that you do.
Right?
So we're aware of the issues with comedy sequels as well.
And so we approached it with that mentality not to go down that kind of road.
And there wasn't any pressure from the studio.
They'd be like,
you have to follow this structure.
Anything.
The pressure is more internal studios if they financing but they didn't finance
it.
So
amongst us there's different opinions about how much,
how referential should be versus you know,
versus not.
You know,
I think,
I think what we said on,
and ultimately we would take maybe one of the old jokes and then we'd put new
spins on it and it allows you to reference it.
But at the same time have a new laugh and the fans,
the fans will be like,
okay,
you gotta a,
you gotta bring back the stoners and you have to have me back to the local cops
and you have to do pull overs and you should do the meow game.
We want you to bulletproof jock strap again.
For sure,
but don't you dare make the same movie as the first one.
Um,
and I guess shenanigans me out,
is that stuff from real life that you guys are pulling from?
Yeah,
no,
no.
I think that's the thing.
Like we,
I think a lot of times we do our best writing when we're hanging out together.
I tried to make in the movies and then you know,
I'll find a thing will pop up and I'll make everybody laugh and it's like,
hey,
let's figure out how to stick that in there,
you know?
And that's where we ended up doing.
I want to talk a little bit,
go back to the Indiegogo campaign campaign because there was some really
interesting,
we did wrench in the best men at a wedding that we talked about.
There was one for naming rights in the film for names of characters of towns
that make it in a few people.
This guy shot,
he fits snugly,
gets his name.
One of my favorite lines in the movie too,
right?
I got to deliver that line and I loved it.
Yeah.
There's like four,
four,
or five names of guy,
people who donated an Indie Gogo and their names are in the movie in one way or
another.
And it's funny because we did get studio notes on the cut of the movie and
they'd be like,
why you say the name shotty Fitz Nutley,
what does it or why is this Matt?
So under the,
why is that name in there?
Why don't you cut for time?
Cut that line out.
I'm like,
wow,
they're investors.
We have to put that,
put that in,
earned it.
Um,
the most ridiculous one,
which there were very,
very shockingly no takers.
The decent proposal.
I'm going to read this because this is ridiculous.
This is it.
And to the Lyme,
if you kick in 25 million and provide our entire tire dream budget,
we will be so grateful that one of us will father your child and all caps,
selling sex as a perk isn't allowed yet.
And our wives went murderous.
But one of us will act as a sperm donor and giving your child a celebrity DNA.
You don't know what you want,
not,
you don't know which one
you put a salad spinner spending up.
Kinda guess we thought,
you know,
I'll be funny we do that.
And then you don't know who you're getting.
So if your kid comes out Indian and then you know who it is or if it gets fat
and you know,
or short or whatever it is.
But maybe it's a hybrid where it comes out short fat,
Brown and Blue Eyes.
But after reading that,
I'm thinking there,
were there any prizes that you didn't include it because they were too
ridiculous?
Cause that is,
I don't know how you can get more ridiculous than that.
What'd you probably can think of?
Which it's an interesting thing like we didn't even realize,
you know,
a lot of this,
the crowd funding it is,
you know,
a cost benefit analysis versus how much of your time can you spend just fulfill
the perks versus the money you raised.
And,
and,
and this is another thing we need from you.
I was like,
you know,
you raised four and a half million bucks and you ended up having like 30 40% go
to the overhead of fulfilling that and then you know,
so I think it was a thing about trying to make sure that whatever we did it was
not so expensive or time consuming,
that immediate kind of ridiculous to do.
You know,
I think we're going to do like,
you know,
private screenings in people's basements or backyards have like parties,
but it was so time consuming,
you just could have funded the schedule to like find the time to fly to a middle
of Oklahoma and I would take a whole three days find there and partying back.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Is there anything that you guys wish that you could have included in the film,
but as you start going through the editing and stuff,
you're just like,
hmm,
that doesn't really work.
But then you watch the final thing and like shit,
I wish up with that.
I mean we,
we,
we cut it and we try to put all the very best stuff in it.
I mean it doesn't,
it's not really a situation where you left out something great.
I think there's a timeliness issue though too.
Like when we shot the first one like we were talking to was 2015,
2016.
I mean it was,
it was,
uh,
it was a joke that Donald Trump was running for president and do them in 15
here.
What I mean,
and now it's a different world.
So like you can't really make those,
like you saw it last night.
We have a,
we have a Stephen Hawking joke in the movie and now it looks like it's in poor
taste and it wasn't,
it was shocked too years ago.
You know,
what the intended to be important.
But now people were like,
oh,
you know,
so that,
that creates a little bit of a problem.
I said,
is there anything,
um,
from the first film that is,
it's a lot of it like sneaks into the pop culture,
like kind of general,
just when you're talking to friends,
like,
I got you good.
You fucker.
Or writing and that kind of stuff where it surprises me that people sometimes
don't associate that with the movie.
They're like,
oh yeah,
people just say that.
It's like,
well no,
that actually came from this film.
Like does anything like that surprise you guys in terms of a line that you're
like,
I can't believe that caught on?
Yeah,
I mean that me out thing is ended up on posters and tee shirts and people get
tattoos of it and these are good
baseball players.
Sneak it into interviews.
But you do,
you do like you just run across these things where you appreciate the fandom and
they're like,
we had someone came to our show and they,
over the years they had collected our autographs and then they tattooed our
autographs onto their forearm.
And you're like,
Jesus.
I mean that's a fan.
There are some horrified looking fascinating.
I mean that's how we fell for like why'd you do that?
I mean that be out joke.
Cause we were all in a room at about four or five in the morning and we were,
we were,
we were smoking in like a,
in a motel.
We were all living five and we were just staying in the motel when we're
pitching TV and we riffed on this idea that a wizard,
what if a wizard turned your tongue,
uh,
into like a a cat and the and but the only way you'd know is because the,
the cat would,
would substitute the word meow for now and we laughed about that for like hours
and somebody wrote on a Napkin,
meow equals now and then three weeks later when we were in a writing meeting for
super troopers,
two someone pulled up an app and you are going remember this joke and you're
like,
yeah,
how are we going to do that though?
And we kind of revamped it and rework it but it is,
that was the scene that every,
we went to every studio to try to get money for the movie and every studio
passed on it and they would talk about that scene.
They're like,
like for instance,
we don't understand this scene here on page 55.
It's got all these [inaudible] hours.
Want to have to go like
two and a half pages of mostly me out.
What is that?
How does that advance the story?
Where's your guys' a biggest pet peeves shouldn't bother me and I know half the
country does it,
but I hate when people say,
I'll do a Margarita.
I sit there,
I sit there seething,
I'm like,
William,
will you do it?
I hate it when a,
when a waiter says,
I've got a three lamb chops left tonight.
I've got a nice cut of Philemon at like he,
I've got that.
You don't got that.
I will say,
hey,
what a waiter asks me if I've ever been there before.
Yeah,
it's a nice rock and business and would order food.
Let's do it doesn't matter if you've been there before,
I guess.
I guess that's scares you.
Just hate restaurant.
I love to see Brian Cox back and I thought that was so,
yeah,
it's fun to see him cause he's gone like really serious.
And I'm like,
so was that a struggle to get him back or was he like,
no,
I'm getting,
Huh?
Oh yeah,
it's fine.
I mean he,
you know,
he's a guy.
When you did the first one,
you know,
he kind of lamented the fact that he didn't get offered comedies a lot.
You know what I mean?
He's a serious actor and he had to get to do comedies and a lot of these actors,
they just want to do something funny here.
So when they get that opportunity they embrace.
So I think when the second time came around he was happy to come back and do it
again.
He was original Hannibal and so you know,
everyone saw him as a serial killer.
No one really could see him.
There's plenty of comedic role and so on.
Our script went out in the wires.
His agents actually read it and sent us Brian's head shot and said Brian would
love to play that part.
Wow.
I want to talk about rob Lowe as well cause he's also in this,
he pleads a car and
he's ridiculous and this and it's so funny cause he does some ridiculous things.
Was that tough getting him to do that?
He has gone to actually mark comedy,
um,
you know,
in the past few years and stuff.
But was that tough to get him kind of on board with that?
I worked with rob on a television show and he was a,
I always joked with him that he was like a comedian stuck in the leading man's
body because he's a very funny guy and his rhythm is perfect,
you know,
either in parks and rec.
He's very,
very funny and he's extremely good luck.
Uh,
but I said to him,
I said,
do you,
would you ever consider being in super troopers?
Because yes.
Any part,
I don't even need to see the script.
And you know,
we have a joke in there that is,
well I'm not going to ruin it,
but it's,
it's a really outrageous joke that he has to do.
And I'm like,
I don't want to show him that joke.
Cause he'll say no,
he'll read the script and be like,
I can't ruin my whole reputation for this movie.
So we cut the joke and these guys were like,
we're not cutting the job.
You're going to make him do that Joe.
And I'm like,
I'll do it.
Let's get them in the movie.
So we got him in the movie and then we were shooting the scene.
These guys are like good over there and told him to do the job.
So I did.
And I started telling the thing and he goes,
oh yeah,
we have to do that.
And then he really elevated it to them.
So hopefully we don't ruin his career.
Will Sasso,
isn't it with Canadians in terms of learning about any of the law or anything
like that?
Because there was that border territory war.
I mean,
I've spent a lot of time shooting television Canada,
so I have,
uh,
you're worried about,
you know,
there's,
they are,
uh,
you know,
there are obviously a smaller country by population and they're,
they're convinced that we're thinking about them.
Right.
And I said,
we're not right.
And they're like,
no,
no.
I mean,
you know,
we all know about the,
the United States government supporting the separatist movement in Quebec
because they're trying to cleave,
that's their word,
cleave the country of Canada in two so that the,
the u s will then sneak up and take all the western oil,
oil interests and leave the east coast.
Cause cause it's,
it's poor.
And I said,
nobody's ever said that down there.
So we thought that'd be kind of like,
you know,
cause that's sort of,
that's sort of,
uh,
a thing that sort of is,
is,
is a part of how the Canadians feel in this movie.
It's like they don't like us coming up there.
And it's true.
I'll tell you this,
you guys don't know this.
This is hot off the presses.
Oh,
uh,
we just received a letter,
I swear to God
from,
uh,
the royal mounted and police accusing us of using their IP illegally.
And uh,
they've said they've sent a legal letter toss now to seize and desist.
It's in your inbox.
Just came in like an hour ago.
Wow.
Did you leave?
That's fine.
You got Atlas,
you have to Canada.
And they're like,
you know,
we did,
we burned down the White House in the war of 18,
12,
eight.
And you look at them funny and then,
you know,
you go look it up on Google and uh,
discover that.
No,
that actually did not happen.
They rented out their land to the British so the British could do it.
Just so you know,
it's in their history books.
That's a birth though.
They burned down,
but they didn't,
um,
the success of the first movie in the fandom around it.
Where there a lot of celebrities in Hollywood that reached out to you asking to
be a part of the film?
I mean,
you just mentioned rob Lowe,
but,
um,
was there anyone who was like,
oh,
I gotta be in your next,
uh,
there,
there were,
and we've,
we've put some of them in a,
and they're,
they're not in the trailer because we kind of wanted to reveal a them when you
go see the movie,
Hey guys,
one sequel in the Ken,
any updates on another potential sequel,
Aka Pot fests.
Slash smoke the problem.
We make one and now you want a different one?
You can see it again.
I haven't seen it yet.
No,
but that was actually one where it's like,
that was supposed to be a joke at the end of beer fest and says,
you know,
really shows up and I'm a part of super secret.
Wayne smoke competition coming soon.
Pop Fest.
Uh,
and then all the Hollywood stoners came out of the woodwork back then.
I mean,
well Willie was like,
we are making this fuckin movie rat and Snoop Dogg,
you know,
said,
he did city sent to invited us for a meeting with him to,
everybody wanted to be at.
So you know,
where if the movie does well,
if super troopers two does well opening weekend,
then that conversation can certainly happen.
Our Future depends on four 20.
I think for a lot of Comedians or actors you've had like call successes,
they often get defined in your career by that and it can probably come back to
haunt you.
You guys have any like Larry stories of being pulled over by the police and
having them do things to you and just be like,
you'd please just give me a ticket.
Uh,
I got pulled over and doing 120 miles an hour.
Um,
I was driving from la up to San Jose on the five north,
if you've been on that,
it's hundreds of miles of pure pristine,
straight black highway.
And I was on the highway after midnight.
I was one of the only cars there.
I was doing one 20.
I was fired up about the fact that there were no cops on this highway.
Uh,
and just when I was really feeling cocky about it,
boom,
the guy got me and uh,
this cop came up with the card.
He was,
he was so mad.
He was like,
Mister,
do you have any idea how fast it super troopers?
I like you got me.
He's like,
oh
my God,
you guys are hilarious.
We play all those games you guys play.
We play the meow game.
We would play the repeater.
I was like bulletproof jockstrap strap.
He's like,
oh,
we're not that fucking crazy.
But then he went on to admit that super troopers was his favorite movie and that
his nickname was Mac after my character.
Uh,
and then he let me out of the speeding ticket and there we were on the side of
the road,
you know,
taking selfies and people are driving by like,
what the fuck?
So that's happened to all of us by the way.
Uh,
I'd love to know your favorite character,
broken lizard or otherwise that you guys have each plate or written?
Yeah,
I'll say far,
but I mean I got say far because he's so fucking crazy.
It's like,
you know,
you did,
you get to do shit that you aren't really allowed to do in the real world when
you play a crazy asshole.
You know what I mean?
And it allows me to,
I don't know,
be a jerk,
I think,
which I think is a lot of fun.
But that's what we try to mix it up in our movies where one guy is the crazy guy
or the two dimensional guy.
And I think we all tried to lobby to get that part because that's always the fun
farm.
Slowly,
you know,
you're really good at it.
Thanks man.
Really just add gum and mustache and gum and yeah,
you're off to the races.
It's deformed.
Uh,
I like playing,
um,
Juan Castillo and club dread.
Uh,
just cause you know,
I got to do an entire movie in a speedo and make out with everybody.
It was awesome.
Thank you very much.
That's my dad's accent right there.
Uh,
I played a character freak your weekend puddle cruiser,
which probably no one in this room have seen,
but it was a movie we made before super troopers and a I,
like Kevin said,
it's the kind of far out character I played as long hippy with long hair and
earrings and uh,
it was fun to go shopping for that kind of character and get into that kind of
weirdness.
Uh,
I think I probably like playing a very bad run eth.
you know,
it's fun to play like a,
a male prostitute,
but try to give it humanity.
Good.
I guess my question is really about with the current industry,
with the Netflix's and the Amazon's kind of throwing a lot of money around and
movies being made and TV shows,
is there any interest in you guys doing some sort of a sketch comedy TV series
or anything like that?
Obviously creating a movie is very difficult,
takes a long time,
but TV shows might be a little bit easier to pump out and allows you guys to
kind of switch between different characters as you guys are used to.
And you're in your sketch comedy background,
are you offering,
I wish it's crazy.
It's,
the landscape has changed so much.
Like he used to go into ABC,
Fox and NBC and CBS and pitch a Sitcom and you'd be like,
yeah,
and you know,
we could do like maybe this episode in this episode and now with like Netflix
and Amazon,
you actually have to have a finished script,
the whole Bible and all prepared.
And then you go,
like,
when you go to like Netflix and Amazon,
those reception areas,
zoo over there.
Now there's pockets of,
of creative teams.
They're all sitting with a celebrity.
Like you're like,
oh,
there's Josh Duhamel and uh,
they're going to go and there's Ed Falco,
they're going to go pitch a TV show with that celebrity there.
It's absolutely a phenomenal film.
I'm so excited for everyone else to see it.
So it comes out on four 20.
Super troopers.
Two.
Thank you guys so much for being here.
Okay.
[inaudible].